[Music]
okay so yeah like I was mentioned I work
at KPMG in the advanced analytics team
and I've been working there for about
two years now and in the last six months
or so I had the opportunity to work
together with another department of our
company which is the sustainability
department and so we had a project
together with these three people
that's me of course and then the host in
the middle she's a colleague of mine
also from the advanced analytics teams
and then later and lots is from
sustainability and what does a lot of
work around the sustainability reports
and what they do typically is they check
these reports for their clients so a lot
of these companies are now not only
reporting on their financial information
they are also reporting on non-financial
information like how are they providing
to the communities or how are they
performing on reducing their emissions
and these topics are becoming much more
important in our daily lives and in
society so also you see that there's
this is reflected in companies writing
more of these reports and one of the
things that they do is sustainability at
our department is that they read these
reports for a client of theirs and they
basically have an opinion about these
reports they say whether or not this
report is good enough to be published
and they have some standards that they
follow which are called the GRI
standards and one of the principles from
these GRI standards is balance and what
balance means is that they wants you
define if a report reflects both the
positive and the negative aspects of a
company's performance so that
stakeholders can make a good assessment
about that performance but the problem
is that one person from the
sustainability Department reads such a
report and then it's entirely up to you
their opinion whether this report is
balanced or not and basically they
wanted to ask us can you somehow make
this balance measurable so we have
something more quantitative to present
to the clients so we tackle this problem
by setting up a case
fellows we had about 800 reports and
which were about 90 pages each and we
splitted the project into three
different parts first part would be to
extract all of the text then we would
focus on getting the different topics
out they were talked about in these
reports and then we would also focus on
the sentiment analysis and now during
this talk I just want to explain the
case that we did and I'm gonna mainly
focus on the last part because let's
face it that's the most interesting part
and but I also want to touch upon what
we did for the first two so that's what
I get into into now for the data
extraction and like I said these reports
all written by different companies so
naturally they all have different
formats different colors there's a lot
of infographics there's a lot of text on
photos so doing stuff like OCR can be
really challenging in these cases and so
instead of doing that we decided to only
focus on the reports that were machine
readable that way we could take
advantage of packages like PDF miner to
get to the XML of these documents and
then get to text out so we would only
get out all the elements that were in
actual text books get the text and then
parse these further to do like some
cleaning I won't get into that there are
some really nice examples already out
there about how you do basic cleaning in
for NOP tasks and but this was good
enough for our case because we could
purse about 29% or four documents that
we had downloaded this way so it was
good enough and then using all of our
newly parsed data we started focusing
first on the topic modeling and now one
of the reasons that it was important to
do this before we did the sentiment
analysis is because we can compare our
sentiment like in general that's sort of
the goal but it's much more interesting
to also look into the specific topics
for the different lines of business like
you would be much more interested in
reading about emissions from an oil and
gas company and maybe a lot more about
product management in a retail company
or about the age
so again the GRI has a long long long
lists about all the different topics
that people should talk about in the
reports but I try to sort of generalize
them in these four main topics so we had
economic topics environmental social and
other so economic you can think about
how to defy to local employment or our
how does their supply chain look
environmental is of course about energy
efficiency but also important to
separate this from water management and
oil and gas social things are more about
employment practices but also a
diversity in hiring health and safety
and the other stuff is more about if
they have new tech available that can
provide in a sustainable way or
corporate governance we try to view
different techniques but the one that
works best for us was just using
unsupervised circuit modeling using LD a
so LD a gives you a multinomial
distribution for F topics for each
document and then for each topic it also
gives you a distribution for its word
and it also assumes that all of the
words that are in one of those documents
are related to each other now what this
means is that if I give it a document
which is a report and I gave it all
these different reports that the topics
that I'm gonna get back is just the
lines of business that these companies
are in so I'm gonna get back to
retailers in the oil and gas stuff but
that's not where we were interested in
we wanted to know that topics that were
discussed inside these documents so
basically what we did we cheated a
little bit and we just gave it all of
the pages and said this is a document we
also filtered out all of the words that
were apparent in all of these documents
or like we're common in most of these
pages and we did some little bit of
filtering on words like company names so
we wouldn't get company specific
information back and then eventually we
got about these 15 topics again I tried
to divide them in the topics that I
highlighted earlier so we found some
business related stuff you can also see
you nicely that it's definitely
sustainability reports that we're
talking about and of course we saw that
in the
environmental stuff we saw again the
separation between the water management
and the emissions which was very
important for our sustainability
colleagues we saw health and safety come
back employee training we also see
diversity in hiring and we see human
rights coming back and so this was a
really nice result for us and having
this model now allowed us to basically
annotate each page in a report as being
part of a signal topic which basically
gave us back all of the chapters that
they were talking about so when we had
this I was finding time for the fun
stuff which was the sentiment analysis
now sentiment analysis is a pretty
common use technique already there's a
lot of research a lot of open source
models that actually do this and they
are very often trained on Twitter
product reviews and but we had a
slightly different question because
these reports are from companies
themselves and they report on their
performance so no company is going to
say well our product kind of sucks and
when we came to this sentiment analysis
we had to ask our sustainability
colleagues how would you then define
your sentiment what would you consider
is positive neutral and negative so they
gave us some definitions positive would
be anything that the company would
classify as an achievement or what they
stated as overly positive good thing
that they did boldly stated
sustainability strategies neutral was
anything that was just factual or things
that were actually a balanced sentence
note it would highlight both positive
and negative things and the negative
things were usually challenges or rested
a indentified or opportunities for
improvement now you can already tell
that this is a pretty sort of hard
distinction to make because even the
negative statements are going to be
worded positively and if we're looking
at words to determine the sentiment how
are we going to distinguish between
something that's worded positively but
is actually negative and things that are
actually positive now I also kind of
want to
try an experiment with you guys which is
I want to know if you can give me the
sentiment for this sentence so I've set
up a mentee meter I don't know if you
guys are familiar with this but it's
basically a website where you can go to
and can fill in this code at the top so
they're 15 24 36 and I just want you to
vote what do you think that this by the
different interest that I just gave you
is a positive and neutral or a negative
statement and now this might blow up
entirely my face because I've never done
this before I'm just really curious to
see how you guys feel about this all
right oh there we go oh okay I'm so
happy all right all right all right
so I mean negative is clearly raining at
this point but we still see that there
are some people that are avoiding
neutral or positive also maybe you guys
a little bit biased now that you see the
negative going up so much you're like oh
well maybe I'll just wait for negative
but this was indeed also the problem
that we had when we try to label these
things so thanks very much for your
participation and we indeed gave one of
our colleagues so we were working
together with his one person and
basically she set up these these
sentiments definitions and she also did
the labeling for us so by her definition
she would go through all these documents
or sentences at least and give it a
label positive neutral negative we then
tried to predict these sentences using
all sorts of different models that are
out there we use commercial things like
it'll set out a text processor to come
we used open source solutions like the
Stanford sentiment tree Bank we even try
to train our own model that was argument
like added with more data from movie
reviews but basically all of these
models just disagreed with each other
and we also didn't Reese see reflected
back what we would expect from like
we say there was a negative sentiment a
lot of these like negative or positively
worded negative sentiments were still
coming back as positive so we needed
something else we needed it as something
that could better understand the like
subtle distinction between a positive
place phrased thing and something that
was actually positive so we needed
something that could understand context
better so we used Bert and Bert is a
quite recent published model from 2018
by Google stands for bi-directional
encoder representations from
transformers which obviously is
backronym but we don't care the model is
a what they call a language
representation model and basically it's
trained to understand the English
language right now they also have
published multiple language models but
at least at that point it was an English
based model and it's strange to predict
certain words in text that's how it sort
of learns to represent English but you
can then use this model to fine-tune
your own models for a different NOP task
and one of those things is obviously
classification and what it uses is just
a sentence as an input with a CLS token
appended at the start of the sweet
sequence and then the representation
that it learns over time is then
reflected in the note that is associated
with this CLS token at the end so that's
that's class label if you see so you can
basically just add a classifying layer
on top of that then fine tune your model
on your classification so that's what we
did Bert has two different types of
models it had the bird base and a bird
large if you want to know more about how
Bert works and about what kind of things
it uses I would really recommend you
looking at this the illustrator
transformer from Jay I'm not gonna try
and pronounce it I think it's a really
really good plot post and it just
explains very generally how the model
works in our case we use bird base the
difference between the two is basically
that bird base has only 12 layers
whereas Bert large has 24 layers
obviously it also performs better
because it has a lot more parameters but
for our case we use Burt based mainly
because it's a little bit faster to
train and also because I am forever
salty that they didn't choose to call
this big Burt because it's not fun and
it's missed a miss this opportunity
so for training we actually used Google
their classifier script so on their
github they provide you with a lot of
examples of how you can do these NOP
tasks that they say bird can be used for
so we just use that because obviously
it's pretty well optimized and it trains
pretty fast so we were not going to try
and replicate or improve on that
basically what you have to give it is a
bunch of parameters how long is your
maximum sequence length what is your
learning rate etc you add your
classifying layer or the script acid for
you actually and and we train a model we
did also eventually ported to Kaos
so we had it available in notebooks and
that was just a lot easier to work with
like even tens of oh now admits that
care house is better because 1002
Pretoria is also going chaos and so
that's what we used for predictions
during like testing and validation and
like I said we got about 3,000 sentences
from well basically mostly litter and
knows a little bit from a colleague it's
um
we only had about three percent negative
labels and 21 percent positive labels
and the rest was all neutral now this is
also obviously another challenge because
I highly unbalanced dataset means it's
gonna be hard to find these sentiments
that were actually interested in we
don't care about the neutral stuff
but we trained Burt Porter to Paris try
to predict some things and this is what
we got and now the neuter is obviously
pretty high but that's not surprising
but we were really happy with the
percentages that we got pretty negative
into positive labels before we were
getting 20% max and so this was already
high point for us and what we were also
really excited about is that it wasn't
the when we looked at the confusion
it wasn't switching any positive with a
net
label and all the confusion was always
between negative and positive negative
and neutral sorry and positive and
neutral and one of the sentences that we
thought was a difficult one which you
also voted on was indeed classified
correctly by Bert so it was able to find
out that this positively phrased
sentence was actually a negative
statements which we wanted to detect
also in the sprint demo over-represented
these these results and we were like
well you know it's it's good but it's
not great but these are the words that
it's or these are the sentences that
it's a bit confused about
we started off immediately with a
50-minute discussion on whether or not
these labels were actually not labeled
wrongly and maybe their model was
correct and maybe she wasn't so
consistent in her own labeling so you're
like okay but if you're not sure about
your labels and how we're going to be
sure that our model is doing what what
you're expecting to be doing and how can
we validate that this is actually useful
but we also knew that this model was
basically trained on one person who
spent two full days just labeling so we
wanted to have a model that was as least
as good as a model that was at least as
good to predict these sentiments as
other people were compared to each other
basically what we did is we asked three
other people can you label a bunch of
sentences for us we gave them all the
same sentences and then we compared them
to Bert now the overall accuracy went
down a little bit but this is not
surprising because we work this model
was pretty heavily biased towards Malta
so we were expecting some differences
but we still saw that there was maybe
one or two cases where it was actually
flipping what they called a positive or
negative sentiments but everything else
was still pretty much on the diagonal
and then when we compare them to each
other they were performing even worse so
okay so what does this tell us well I
also like it was a little bit curious
about how this then looked at if you
the words in in well if you plot it on
basically so what I did is remember this
see your last token that I was talking
about before which is what you use as an
input for your classifier these are
basically just the vectors that
represent your sentences so I just used
these vectors and through some PCA or
tease me over it so I could plot the
things and knew what I was looking at
and so what happened is that when you
look to these plots so this is Bert
versus litter and obviously the more
darker colors are the labels by lota and
the little lighter colors you see in the
back those are the predictions by Birds
so we can clearly see that what we have
all over negative sentences down here
this all over negative sentences are a
little bit down here you're most of the
positive ones in the rest is sort of
neutral but we do see that there's like
one or two-sentence and this in between
and when I started to actually like look
into these sentences if they were
different I also sort of thought that
mota wasn't really super consistent with
herself and it's also really interesting
to look at Bert versus the other people
and then you can clearly see that all of
these positive labels are all in just
like big blue blob over here I hope you
guys can see it if I need to zoom in to
sell me that better so okay so what is
the actual conclusion of this like how
is this still useful well basically what
we discovered is that what they already
knew this entire balance exercise that
they do is so much dependent on one
person's opinion how can you go to a
client and say well your balance is off
you need to change this well that's just
their opinion and the client is
obviously going to have another opinion
and then their colleague is also going
to have another opinion so what we
actually did give them is a possibility
to make at least their analysis of all
of the reports consistent yeah that's us
so they now have a way to make actually
make something that they can benchmark
against each other so they have a
sentiment score for one report but they
also have it for the peers of their
clients and they can compare and say
from hey except you're being pretty
negative compared to your competitor so
maybe you can you know marketed yourself
a little bit better on the other hand
maybe you're being too positive and you
need to scale it down a little bit and
we can actually show you that you are
because we can compare you to your
competitors now another big benefit of
course is that we have this entire field
database now with all of these reports
with their topics with their sentiment
scores so there's another like whole
avenue of other analysis we can now do
we can track trends in time we can see
that maybe if a company has to change
the CEO does it doesn't mean there's a
sentiment changes and how does it change
is they're trending different topics
that people are discussing is there a
difference in topics that peers are
discussing should they be discussing
others there's also such a thing as a
GRI Award winner for the best
sustainability report it could be very
interesting to look into if there's like
some sort of way we can determine if
you're going to be a winner like maybe
we can leverage that to the client um so
currently they are using this database
to look at these reports they have a
this is one report per page and it's
aggregated for the sentiment and also
for the topics so they can see this is
actually our KPMG annual report which
also has a stuff about our
sustainability in there and now you can
see this whole big blob over there
that's all financial information which
has no sentiment except this negative
one I'm just also this big giant blob
here in the front is our disclaimer
which is just one sentence but obviously
that's lack of this being a risk so so
they now use these things to compare to
their peers we did a comparison to our
competitors so who are in PwC Deloitte
just to see like how are we comparing to
them and this is very
useful for us now to see how we're doing
but also for sustainability to talk to
their clients about um are there any
questions
[Applause]